et pour terminer ce journal sur la même
partition l'ouverture d'un musée très
attendu le musée de la musique c'est la
touche finale de la cité de la musique à
la villette
il accueillera ses premiers visiteurs
dans une semaine pour un voyage à
travers les instruments de toutes les
époques de la renaissance au xxème
siècle un très beau musée découvert en
avant première par rosanna vanille sion
et jacques gauthier
la plupart des pièces présentées dans ce
musée dormait depuis des décennies
parfois même des siècles dans les locaux
du conservatoire de paris
aujourd'hui après une vaste campagne de
restauration
les voilà enfin qui s'ouvre au public
leur écrin un musée de 3000 m² qui sur
quatre niveaux présente de la
renaissance à nos jours 900 instruments
de musique
c'est un projet très ambitieux il là le
désir de faire venir autour de
collection d'instruments et deux
tableaux de documentation un public qui
n'est pas un public de spécialistes
alors qu'en général le ceux qui
fréquentent les musées d'instruments
dans le monde sont plutôt des
spécialistes il est certain que les
collections une part prépondérante sur
le xviie et le xviiie et convoyage
surtout à travers l'europe
mais les musiques du monde sont assez
présentes et en particulier à travers le
continent asiatique
un musée de la musique non un musée des
musiques avec des instruments venus des
quatre coins du monde comme ceux gamelan
asiatiques
c'est un instrument qui est encore
national en indonésie jouer partout dans
les palais comme dans les villages et
même en europe
aujourd'hui le gamelan rencontre un
succès croissant puisqu'on en trouve
dans beaucoup de l'institution et la
cité de la musique possède elle-même
aussi un gamin très très fréquenté cette
vienne s'arrondit die du nord date du
xviie siècle c'est une pièce unique
tambours de poitrine zaïrois avec cet ex
culte et il n'en existe qu'un exemplaire
au monde
mais le musée de la musique est aussi
ouvert sur le xxème siècle et ses
instruments électroacoustique reflet des
recherches contemporaines les plus
récentes
un musée vivant où les instruments sont
là aussi pour se faire entendre et jouer
grâce à des bornes interactives et des
concerts organisés ponctuellement dans
l'amphithéâtre de la cité de la musique